mesquite motor mania is back this
weekend and here to tell us about it is
christian adderson with the casablanca
resort who is sponsoring this segment i
love when you're in studio because when
you're in studio that means some fun's
about to happen absolutely you're
bringing fun to mesquite this weekend
what is the history of this event yeah
mosquito motor mania we're going to our
14th year we started out 14 years ago
with about 300 cars a great group of
spectators that came up to it and every
year it gets bigger and better and we're
14 years we're gonna be 900 cars
and our crowds just keep getting bigger
and better and people just come out and
just have a great time it is a blast out
there we're seeing some photos of some
of the cars that you guys have out there
in years past there's all kinds of
events that take place what is taking
place this weekend around the vehicles
yeah i think that's one of the great
parts about this event is you get to see
these beautiful vehicles and vote for
your favor but you get to see what's
under the hood and we have an open
header cruise on friday and saturday uh
brewing engine competition
slow drags burnout competition so you
can see these beautiful cars parked in
the show and shine areas but you'd see
what's under the hood and that's kind of
the most important thing during that and
the owners are there too because with
every car there's a story and i love
just talking to the owners of the cars
and they give you the back story on
their cars
we go back a step what's a slow drag
what's that so it's actually you idle
the car as slow as you can and they and
they have the the light tree just like a
drag race and they just go out and the
slowest person to go over the finish
line actually wins so the slower is
better in that
context
now if someone's watching right now can
people still enter their vehicles this
weekend yeah absolutely bring bring your
vehicle up to the costa blanca resort
it's 70 to register on site just head in
the showroom at casablanca you can
register your car right on site and
there are packages too because
casablanca resort it's an easy drive up
there it's a three-day weekend for many
people this weekend so you can make a
weekend out of it any specials going on
with the hotel yeah we got great hotel
room rates all through the weekend so
make sure you give us a call and go to
casablanca resort dot com and grab your
room and the people that are walking
around the show
the show can they they're voting on cars
and we'll eventually crown a winner on
sunday yeah the best part of this is
free to the public to attend yes so
bring the whole family up you get the
vote for your favorite car and those go
to the results uh for for the people's
choice and then we have a best in show
so get up there vote for your favorite
car it does go to the overall winners a
question though are pets allowed because
it's a great outdoor event family
friendly free to get in can you bring
your dog and walk around and check out
those cars yeah absolutely it's a
family-friendly event so when we're
outside looking at cars bring the dog
along it's part of the family bring them
on up there and uh everyone can enjoy
the outdoor and all these beautiful cars
we'll have at mesquite motormania
christian we'll see you this weekend the
weather is going to be fantastic up
there hey it's looking great so like i
said if you're a car fan you got to get
up to the casablanca resort and check
out mesquite motor mania i'll see you
sunday sounds good mesquite motor mania
is happening friday through sunday
january 16th it is free you can call
877-438-2929
or visit casablanca resort dot com las
vegas now we'll be right